although typically viewport is only
being set on load you can actually play
around with the viewport settings in the
development tools to tweak it and get it
just right if I go into the page and set
the viewport meta element contents from
the mobile dev tools it will change the
page as if it had been refreshed however
and this is where it gets a bit
confusing the zoom level is maintained
by the browser across page refreshes so
when you change viewport settings in the
source code and you're reloading be sure
to actually close the tab first don't
just hit reload or it won't necessarily
show the effects on the screen for
example let's go back to our last bit of
code and change that width to something
really different let's double the width
to 1832 and now let's save that to the
server and reload it on our mobile
device our new viewport setting doesn't
take effect on the other hand if we
close the tab first and then reopen it
our new viewport setting now takes
effect so pro tip always remember to
close the tab